hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i wanted to talk
about
this xbox bethesda news that broke today
uh because there's something about it
that i just really want to highlight
uh that i feel like i haven't spoken a
lot about on this channel before that i
think is a pretty big deal that i'm also
not seeing
enough people talk about i think in case
you missed the news wow
um this had kind of been hinted at for a
while honestly
but still didn't expect it and when i
saw the amount of money involved it's
just
painful to look at just so much money
okay so this is a post from uh the xbox
newswire news.xbox.com
uh written by phil spencer head of xbox
apparently
i always wonder how true that kind of
thing is did phil really write this
or was it like a team of pr reps and
then it said phil
i don't know i genuinely don't know the
title is welcoming the talented teams
and beloved game franchises of bethesda
to xbox and goes on to say critically
acclaimed creators of the elder scrolls
fallout wolfenstein doom dishonored
quake starfield and more
join team xbox today is a special day as
we welcome some of the most accomplished
studios
in games industry to xbox we are phil
we are thrilled to announce microsoft
has entered into an agreement to acquire
zany max media parent company of
bethesda
softworks the phrasing of this means
that this deal isn't like 100 done for
the record
uh but i think it's probably pretty well
done so yeah this means that xbox would
be
inheriting i guess 2 300 people
worldwide
including bethesda softworks bethesda
game studios in software
and my love xanniemax online studios
arcane
whom i love machine games tango
gameworks alpha dog and roundhouse
studios um all great teams
all made a lot of really good stuff
shout out to arcane
of course this is in part a game pass
play uh it says just as they took
the bold first steps to bring the elder
scrolls franchise to the original xbox
bethesda were early supporters of game
pass bringing their games to new
audiences across devices and have been
actively investing in new gaming
technology like
cloud streaming of games we will be
adding bethesda's iconic franchises to
xbox game pass for consoles and
pc one of the things that has me the
most excited is seeing the road map of
the person's future games some announced
and many unannounced to xbox console and
pc including starfield
the highly anticipated new space epic
currently in development by bethesda
game studios
so there are a couple of like base
things what i don't what go
away go away bloomberg number one
7.5 billion dollars
is so much money oh my gosh uh but i did
want to highlight this particular thing
let's just get rid of these ads shall we
i don't mind seeing them
supporting uh you know your writers but
uh you guys don't have to see them so
this does
specifically mention uh bethesda working
more tightly with sony recently uh
previously agreeing to debut two of its
upcoming games death loop and ghostway
tokyo seriously i think death loop
has shot up to like my number one most
hyped next-gen game
like like i said i love arcane i'm so
stoked about that game i cannot wait
i'll be playing it on ps5 because they
confirmed
that uh it is still being honored
basically that deal the two games will
be restricted to the playstation 5 for a
fixed period of time before coming to
xbox
that's staying exactly the same they did
also know future games like starfield
will be available for xbox pc and
microsoft's game pass video game service
and then
phil said we will take other consoles on
a case-by-case basis
i generally hope that bethesda's
franchises are still available to
playstation users across the board i
think exclusive suck for gamers and i
get that like people who
care about console wars um don't feel
that way because you've like pledged
allegiance to a
multi-million dollar corporation for
some reason but generally i would want
everyone to have access to these games
and i feel like this one particularly
stands out because
bethesda's games have been so huge um
and
been cross-platform for such a long time
worth noting it is not considered a
monopoly i did see some people talking
about that legally it's not at all a
monopoly i don't think they're even
close this isn't like a kind of fox deal
it certainly like
doubles the the uh xbox library but it
doesn't
doesn't apply as a monopoly legally um
that's been confirmed
so that's what i hope but that's just a
personal thing i think uh exclusives
across the board limit more people from
playing games and
my stance is that i want everyone to
play all of the games all of the time
because games are great
and i'm very much a person who likes
video games not a person who likes
a particular brand of hardware that is
um definitely how i function
but to get to the point of this that i
really wanted to talk about that i think
is is huge
and that i know that like probably a lot
of people watching this video won't
um even necessarily care about hearing
but i still want to air it for those of
you who
do for those of you who who might be
open to hearing this kind of thing
it's certainly no secret that i think
game pass is great value i think
probably a big part of that even for me
comes from growing up in a family that
didn't have a lot of money
my first console was second hand and
broke
and you know we had to rent games
because we couldn't really buy them
some of them we'd get from like friends
who were done with them and lend them
but mostly just a lot of
renting where possible which means
sometimes i didn't even get to finish
video games
and then my second generation of
consoles was exactly the same was
something that we had to buy second hand
and i was limited in what games i could
get in any given year you know i had to
like
pick very carefully what i wanted for a
birthday or for christmas um
and often ask for things that were you
know really cheap
often weren't new releases uh because
they were cheaper
so i think like maybe that like you know
people have it way harder than me but
what i'm saying is maybe that
just because i have that perspective
this is the thing that i'm very focused
on game pass getting every
bethesda game day and date releases on
game pass
is so good for accessibility um
in a way that i hope that this puts
pressure on the entire industry frankly
to have more of a focus on accessibility
one obviously
it means that people with lower incomes
families with lower incomes
or people in countries uh someone on
twitter actually pointed this out to me
and i appreciate them than pointing it
out because i hadn't even considered it
people in developing countries where
their dollar is potentially a lot weaker
those people are so limited in what
games that they can buy in a year
because video games are expensive it is
a luxury hobby at this point
every new game that you get on game pass
but especially when it is a triple a
publisher like bethesda with franchises
that people have loved
absolutely forever is just so awesome
for those people
for people who can't afford games for
for families who have to make tough
decisions
on you know what one they can buy a year
or what two they can buy a year
the second part of that is the disabled
community this is something that i'd not
even considered until i asked uh steve
saylor
who you might know is blind gamer he's
just snowball on youtube
to uh be a guest on dude soup which is
the podcast that we run at the company
that i work for
funhouse and basically he mentioned that
uh people with disabilities often don't
even know if they can play a game
until they've already bought it and put
an hour in and
uh for example obviously and a lot of
companies don't have good refund
policies
i definitely want to give a shout out to
my home country australia for being
great about refunds thank you for that
but basically people with with
significantly inhibiting disabilities
don't know that they can't play a video
game until they've already bought the
video game
game pass removes that risk for disabled
gamers it's also
that frequently gamers with disabilities
have
a lot more trouble getting into the job
industry they're like i phrased that
strangely it can be harder for people
with disabilities to get jobs
meaning they are often also unable to
buy video games game pass being as cheap
as it is
and uh having the wealth of games that
it does is so
helpful for people like that you don't
have to worry as much about
uh potentially spending 60 on a game
especially here in the us
that you could find out an hour in that
you can't even play when you have game
pass it kind of doesn't even matter
and when you have triple a games on game
pass like bethesda games
it just removes this entire barrier from
a group of people
who otherwise have been you know a lot
of times just forgotten about where
video games are concerned
and while i do have my concerns with
game pass
um from all the devs i've spoken to it
does seem like it is actually
financially very good for developers
uh generally it seems like my developers
are concerned it's a positive i don't
know what it means for
uh game development cycles i don't know
if it means we're going to be getting
lesser uh shorter games overall and
that's something that i think microsoft
still has to prove like sure we know
that you're acquiring these studios but
really what games are these studios
making um about looks incredibly
promising obviously but
uh outside of that i'm not yet convinced
about
how the game pass model impacts the
video games themselves
but just i guess generally speaking this
happening today feels like a huge win
for accessibility and i want to i want
to put a highlight on that for everyone
who's forgetting that in this
conversation about how important that is
for anyone who doesn't know i am a board
member on
a charity called checkpoint checkpoint
is all about
the relationship between mental health
and video games and how video games can
help with mental health how they can
have tremendously positive
impacts on a lot of people and i think
just something about the idea that that
people with
disabilities that can often prevent them
from going outside
that can make uh socializing a lot more
complicated or people who are less
fortunate who don't have
uh the money to buy whatever games they
want it seems especially unfair that
those people
would not get access to the mental
health benefits of
playing video games so i just kind of
wanted to air that
i do also want to give a shout out to
naughty dog the last of us part 2 does a
tremendous job where video game
accessibility is concerned
but just generally think i can do a
better job of being an advocate for
the um disabled community where the
stuff is concerned
and i guess that's why i wanted to
highlight this uh not
for me to tell you that you know
microsoft is doing this
um more for me to point out that one
benefit that i think a lot of people
don't
consider just so that if you've never
even considered that before but you're
aware of it
that the disabled community can often be
an afterthought when it comes to gaming
and i want them in gaming and i want us
to do a better job of including them in
gaming
and this is a step that definitely helps
them and i'm very happy to see it
ultimately
but yes naturally still have some
broader concerns about where
uh games on game parts are concerned
i've literally said that to phil
directly said it to him and was like but
what kind of games you're going to be
making is this going to change the
landscape
i'm a little bit scared i really like
video games and i don't like micro
transactions
but that's besides the point i just
wanted to give a shout out to steve
sayla
to gamepass uh even unintentionally
helping that community which related
uh if you guys haven't heard of
ablegamers charity i very highly
recommend
checking them out um they are currently
doing a massive fundraiser for
steve spawn's birthday steve who's a
good friend of mine is trying to raise a
million dollars for ablegamers for his
40th birthday
to i guess his pitch was have ablegamers
uh the charity that he is the ceo of
outlive him was the idea and while the
idea of anything
bad happening to steve breaks my heart i
would also love to contribute to
helping ablegamers um make a million
dollars
to help steve reach his birthday goal
and help
uh as it says this is on shaq news that
we're reading this right now
to help those with disabilities continue
experiencing this great hobby we
all share the team helps source or make
equipment that will let those with
disabilities play on so it's a very good
thing to have
um shout out to that i'll leave a link
in the description below if you want to
find out more but you know realistically
i know you're all going to argue about
console walls and call me a shell and
[ __ ] so
just try to just try to be positive
about a good thing please don't yell at
me okay
bye everyone